Đó tán nếu mà lọc các bạn chẳng quan tất cả những cái đồ về xương tả ta sức thíy,
dụ chính bà hơi thíy dụ như kịp là hãy vận văn bận là ta hãy xương xong.
Lớm lên, nó sóng về cân, mô sinh bằng việc nhật ra.
Lớm nặp bây đập sau về đen ông trợ thành gửi nấu tý, mạnh tròn tịch, xúc hầu đi mì.
Em đo không làm của bài ra, bởi vì mệt không có được lâu.
Đa còn một phục viên bây gây xả mật là một bân dễ người đó.
Vướng mơ tổng tư ra, goi dạ đến là cái gì, bởi rằng bằng đàng ở ta cời.
Vướng án gian nhìn, goi ra với đúng tổng.
bởi bị khi mình quá khổ của nó, không c態 thì tự nãy gian.
Từ một cầu bế hậu dạng mơ ước tất tương lành.
I wanna use the good to look well to fix the skin.
phòng phù trí phát mừng thái phát mình dừng tập đi trước đó thống.
Em ngay nào mà mình bắt đầu dừng phát mừng mà các phát mình mình kế mà đối tổ ra
đang ngay đó mà nên bạn có vận công ty rồi trước.
Khách mời của chúng tôi hôm nay là tính sĩ Lương Vị quốc,
chào mừng quý vị quay trả lại với the first step.
Đó first step là nơi trước tôi sẽ tròn chuyện với những người giật phần
là nghe li cho họ khởi tạo và cắt họn trước thật.